una contra ofensiva que está cambiando
el curso de la guerra
Desde los primeros días de septiembre y
hasta hoy nuestros guerreros han
liberado más de 6000 kilómetros
cuadrados del territorio de Ucrania en
el sur y el este los avances de nuestras
fuerzas continuaron en las ciudades y
pueblos liberados se vieron amplias
sonrisas como en estos soldados
ucranianos que fueron aclamados como
Héroes sentimos la misma emoción cuando
liberamos la región de sumi cuando te
encuentras con residentes felices que te
dicen por fin están aquí es mucha
emoción tras los rápidos avances
ucranianos los restos de La retirada
rusa quedan al descubierto desde tanques
con la letra z hasta equipos de
comunicación y lo más importante las
reservas de munición vamos a enviar toda
esta munición a los rusos como un
pequeño regalo nos hace felices poder
hacerlo en las primeras horas en la
ciudad de edición el humo seguía
saliendo de los edificios signo de
varios días de intensos combates la
ciudad sirvió como base estratégica de
reabastecimiento para el ejército ruso
pero hoy lavanderá azul y amarilla
vuelve a ondear entre las ruinas decir
que estoy feliz es un eufemismo no tengo
palabras para expresarlo
tuvimos lágrimas en los ojos llevamos
seis meses esperando a nuestros soldados
no pensábamos que llegarían tan rápido y
estamos muy contentos
Moscú había calificado su retirada como
una reagrupación planeada De antemano
pero durante el fin de semana la
televisión Estatal como yo de tono
admitiendo que Rusia había abandonado su
principal bastión en el noreste a pesar
del revés el ejército ruso dijo que
bombardeos zonas retomadas por Ucrania
cerca de como esta subestación eléctrica
provocando apagones generalizados